what up space fam glozen here from anime
uproar and it's officially here the time
we've all been waiting for the new part
of season two has officially begun the
part covering the entertainment district
arc and of course i'm here to talk about
it if you do enjoy seeing these
demonstrator videos on the channel i
want to keep them coming then set your
heart ablaze and smash that like button
with no mercy like zero mercy remember
smashing that like button is hoshida
energy and passing is demon king of pop
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future demonstrator videos and updates
feel free to leave suggestions in the
comments for demonstrator topics you are
burning up to see and let me know if
you'd like to see episode reviews for
each episode of this new season and
while you wait for the next episode to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing demonstrator playlist that
includes videos in all the hashida demon
moons and most recently on how strong
upper moon 1 is and much more linked to
that is in the description and now
without further ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all the cool thing about
this episode which is called sound
hashiratangan uzu is it's double the
length of a usual episode at 47 minutes
and i'm very glad they decided to start
the new arc in such a flashy way warning
i may be regularly including puns in
this video and not acknowledging the
fact that i'm doing so this episode
starts after the mugen train arc where
then goku the flame hashira was the
focus i did a video on the special anime
original episode on goku and i had a
positive view on it i like the fact that
by the time we get on the train with him
he felt more like a friend than a
stranger we grew very attached to the
manly flame hashira and then we were hit
right in the fields all the harder when
he died from the wounds upper moon three
akasa inflicted on him the animation for
this new entertainment district dark has
stayed nice let me know if you think
it's on the same level as season one or
not in the beginning we follow muzon a
bit who now has taken the form of a
child in the manga we just sort of saw
him as a kid when akaza stopped by and
we're led to assume the rest but the
anime has been adding more stuff and i
think it works sometimes pillars can
suck don't get me wrong but since
demonstrator was so fast-paced in the
manga i like the fact that they are
fleshing some of the stuff out for
instance in this case it's explained
that muzon was adopted by some parents
who couldn't have a biological child of
their own and they are psyched to have
such an intelligent adopted child and
brag about him it's also explained that
they think he has a medical condition
that prevents him from going out in the
sun which explains how he could live
with this family without them getting
suspicious it also suggests that muzon
is really playing the role of prodigy
child well which is interesting to note
that he'd go that far i really like the
fact that muzan can take so many forms
and it explains how he's been able to
avoid being detected by the demonstrator
core for so long although at this point
even if they found him they couldn't
really beat him in my view unless of
course they could somehow drag him out
into the sun akaza shows up to see kid
moves on and the blue spider lilies are
mentioned that may be the key to muzon
becoming immune to the sun and the fact
that akasa took out a hashira is
mentioned as well muzon is infuriated
though that akaza is acting like that
that's something to brag about and
points out how unacceptable it is that
he let the other demon slayers go this
is a failure in his mind and we get a
glimpse into his power even though akaza
killed rengoku one of the strongest
hashira here he's powerless before muzon
who is effortlessly making him cough up
blood and feel immense pain it's pretty
much implied that unless they escape his
grasp somehow like tamayo and nezuko
muzon can pretty much destroy demons
from inside out which is fitting for the
demon king of pop that's pretty much why
even while the demon moons change we
can't really see someone replacing
muzon's position as the demon king and
him being able to overpower akuza like
this pretty much making akas a bow
before him also shows how much more the
demon slayers have to improve if they
can ever hope to defeat muzon and put an
end to all demons akasa gets upset
punches tundra to sword until it
crumbles and promises to get vengeance
against tanjiro the boy who stabbed him
in the back literally and called him a
coward thus a very interesting battle is
set up for down the line here tundra
versus akaza part two and i'm very
excited for that we then jump to some
less intense stuff like zany to stealing
food from ali there is more emphasis on
how hard tanjiro and inosuke are taking
the loss of rengoku tundra was told to
rest up because of how bad his stomach
wound was but instead he follows her and
goku's crow and the crow is guiding him
to goku's father's house sincere and
goku's father might have the info tundra
was searching about in regards to
hinokami tanjiro meets up with senjuro
and goku's little brother and the dad
finally shows up he's a drunk that
insults her in goku's memory saying he
was a fool he wasn't talented enough so
of course he died he talks about how
everyone's talent is determined at birth
so one should just give up if they're
not one of the chosen few like rengoku
clearly this is a disillusioned dude a
pessimist and contrasted in goku's
undying optimism this is a common thing
we see in shonen the fate versus hard
work question and although i don't think
demonstrator is super optimistic about
it either for instance not everyone
through hard work and willpower can
become stronger than akaza for example
still i think it's pretty obvious it
also rejects this extreme of believing
that if you're not the strongest and
most talented then there's no point in
trying yeah then goku worked hard and it
wasn't enough to beat akaza but because
he worked so hard and tried he was able
to save tundra zainto ninosuke all of
whom may prove to be very valuable in
the eventual defeat of muzon so the
point of demonstrator is not don't try
but rather it's do your best and if you
do do your best the effort will not be
pointless and make sure to drop a like
if you laughed when i said doodoo back
to the rude drunk dad as tundra stands
in to defend rengoku the dad sees
tundra's earrings and he snaps he says
that tundra is a wielder of sun
breathing aka he's suggesting that
hinokami is sun breathing the father
attacks tundra sanjiro and just overall
is a crazy dude we're told that sun
breathing is the first style ever
created the strongest of all and all
others are just inferior copies we also
see another shot of the demonstrator
with the red blade and same earrings he
was also an op user of sun breathing the
dad thinks that tundra is arrogant
because he is a user of this chosen and
best style but in fact it's quite the
opposite tundra is angry that despite
knowing this so-called best technique he
wasn't able to do anything he was
powerless to save rengoku so although
tanjuro may have the potential to
surpass rengoku he's not there yet and
it will take a lot more hard work to get
there even the dad who's a former
hashira is able to get some really solid
hits on tundra despite probably being
super drunk right now but luckily when
everything else fails tundra still has
his head butt and the headbutt is able
to end the fight senjiro even thanks
tundra for beating up his dad in a sense
because he couldn't stand up for his
brother himself it's explained that
senjuro would have been the next blame
hashtag but he wasn't skilled enough so
tundra is sort of set up here as rengoku
symbolic tsuguku or hashira successor
senjuro even gives tanjiro and goku
sword guard eventually so tundra will
sort of be carrying rengoku's will in
every upcoming battle a detail which i
really like a lot we also see tanjiro
talking about how he can't improve in an
instant and i really like that although
he is arguably a kind of chosen one as
the only known user of sun breathing
right now it's still gonna require
insane effort experience and consistency
for him to actually master it and until
he does master or at least get a lot
closer to mastering it he'll probably
even have trouble reaching kashira level
even if those hasha are using
quote-unquote inferior styles it's a
nice balance of work and talent and i
appreciate that view versus a too
optimistic or too pessimistic view
lastly we get a touching moment where we
see that goku's dad is actually feeling
a lot of pain inside he thought rengoku
might resent him after he was so bad to
him but rengoku just told him to take
care of himself and you really feel it
when he breaks into tears and starts
crying uncontrollably for his dead son
clearly although it doesn't excuse it
his rudeness and drinking is masking his
pain first from his wife's passing and
now from his oldest son's passing as
well first endeavor and now this guy i
don't know what it is with firebase dads
being so messed up oh yeah and i almost
forgot zuko's dad too but let's carry on
we then proceed to tundra trying not to
get murdered by his swordsmith for
losing his sword he is saved by none
other than ali and that's another part
which was expanded on the running was
definitely longer than in the manga and
i like how they gave aoi a bit more
attention and focus here too even though
she's not a fighter she's showing how
useful she can be and in this case she
knew the smith's favorite food and gave
it to him to calm him down we then
proceed to see our main characters
recovering and training saints of course
is motivated by nezuko he begged for a
lock of nezuko's hair saying he'd do his
best on solo missions if he got it now
tell me in the comments is that creepy
or is that sweet i have no idea and he
also just screamed her name when he
needed motivation which was hilarious
clearly the zanitsu nezuko ship is being
built up quite a bit here and i
appreciate that although we could use
some more from nezuko's side not just
any twos we also see tundra and nezuko
go on an anime only mission where they
need to take out a kind of demon with
insect-like limbs it's some much needed
action since we had very little demon
slaying in this almost hour-long special
episode the insect demon gets cornered
and tundra beats him with water
breathing not even needing to resort to
sun breathing and it was nice seeing
tundra finish the demon off i enjoyed
the way he shifted back to slice his
head very aesthetically pleasing was
this demon conflict revolutionary or
especially good not really but it was an
appreciated addition since obviously
there were missions in the manga too
they just weren't shown so it's nice to
get a taste of what tanjo and nisko were
up to before the sound hashtag shows up
to kidnap ali as tundra is coming back
he hears aoi screaming kanel really
shines here because she has to overcome
all her prior training conditioning and
trauma and listen to her heart as tundra
told her to despite a superior officer
ordering her not to interfere she does
anyways and grabs ali it's such a
touching moment and builds the tundra
and canal ship as well it's hilarious
how they all end up jumping on him and
when tundra shows up it isn't even clear
who is bothering whom tundra goes to use
the super effective headbutt again to
solve problems but for once he misses as
tangent just dodges i love tanjun how he
just refuses to acknowledge someone so
mean as a hashira and they even call him
a pervy dude and he definitely doesn't
help matters when he slaps ali's butt
before releasing her at one point it was
kind of hilarious how he just dropped
one of the girls when he found out that
she wasn't a demon slayer with his
clueless behavior this guy definitely
looks like the inosuke of the hashira
it's such an epic moment when zainson
and nosuke show up and all three offered
to go in ali's place science was freaked
out but still offers and the nosque is
classic confident inosuke and actually
offers to help before zhanitsu so
inosuke offering to help aoi interesting
stuff a third possible ship is building
between these two it is at this point
that tangent tells them that they're
going to the entertainment district and
we see a lady demon controlling sashes
like a more attractive doc ock and then
we see the outro which is glorious i
gotta say with a lot of spoilers as well
i may get into that more at a later date
but i don't want to spoil too much here
but for now i hope you enjoyed this
first episode and of course this review
of it it was more so setting stuff up
than an action-packed episode but it was
necessary and i'm so glad we are
officially into the new arc let me know
if you're hyped if you liked it and if
you liked all the new stuff that they're
adding to the anime specifically do you
appreciate the anime only stuff i do
like it so far because they aren't going
overboard with it as long as you don't
get multiple episodes of only bad filler
i'll be a happy camper also let me know
how you like tengen the hashira star of
this arc he's definitely not in goku
which is actually nice we wouldn't want
them all to be the exact same right that
would be kind of boring so i like how
every hashtag has their own powers look
but also personality and yeah that is it
for the first episode of this brand new
arc so glad it's finally here and as i
mentioned before this is one of my
favorite arcs so it'll only get better
from here if you're excited too and
enjoyed this review you know what to do
set your heart ablaze and smash that
like button with no mercy zero mercy
remember smashing that like button is
hashida energy and passing is demon king
of pop energy so you know choose wisely
if you haven't yet make this the video
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future demonstrator videos and
updates feel free to leave suggestions
in the comments for demonstrate topics
you are burning up to see and let me
know if you'd like to see episode
reviews for each episode of this new
season and while you wait for the next
episode to drop feel free to check out
my huge and growing demonstrator
playlist that includes videos on all
hashira demon moons most recently on how
strong upper moon 1 is and much more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord wigo himself alpha
sigma and or the one tier patrons the
ones who stay on top all clans ingrata
al-jatal pate hepa the red-haired fox
hinokami and water the toasted chi corey
mcgowan the spike lonely dakar dylan
isadore spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkis big buddhist jeremy cummings and
che a whitley and our pro here to your
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz very gucci alicia
actor bonnie parks joanne garcia fat boy
games kylo might be a duck jessica
rabbit jeremy phillips ali vaitna and
temple thank you all so much if you do
enjoy our work you can support more of
it by going over to patreon.com
animeapro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you get a name feature in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank meme so check out patreon.com
anime outro link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see you space cowboys
[Music]
don't
[Music]